I was just in Vegas I went to a diner
like 4 AM 5 a.m and there's the
waitresses empty as a waitress that was
the sweetest kindest human being kept
calling me sweetheart and all that kind
of stuff hun
and then after I ate she sat down and
just talked to me a little bit you know
it's because there's nobody nobody there
and it was just so much sadness in her
eyes I don't know but it's also so much
love like that sweetheart
that I mean it reminded me kind of um
of the John Candy performance because at
first because I was like uh reading a
pretty dark uh
uh book about Hitler uh so I was a
little bit frustrated that she kept
talking to me because it was like uh it
was it was almost like uh the same way
that John Candy is it's annoying a
little bit right but then very quickly I
opened up to like oh this is
there's a kind human being and there's
like that human connection superseded
everything else and I don't know it was
just beautiful and I think John Candy
captures that
really well which is like the connection
with other human beings sometimes
we pull away from that because we have a
busy life full of stuff to do uh as
um Steve Martin's character kind of
characterize he's like a marketing exec
or something like that but
if you just pause and notice others you
can you can really discover beautiful
people